welcome back
I'm sorry to say that this is our last
lecture
I've had a lot of fun introducing you to
ancient Egyptian hieroglyphs and I hope
you've enjoyed it as much as I have
since its graduation day I have to
prepare you for the real world life
after a course on deciphering
hieroglyphs so I'll be suggesting how
you can continue your studies of
hieroglyphs places to visit things to
read
but first we'll conclude our translating
with two objects from two tank almonds
tomb let's start with a magical mirror
there were many cosmetic and toilet
objects in the Tomb
but the most beautiful was a mirror case
in the shape of an ankh
the mirror itself was missing probably
stolen by the tomb robbers due to the
value of the metal
This Modern reproduction is what the
mirror probably looked like based on the
case discovered in the Tomb
it's shaped like an akh the hieroglyph
for life
well the word for mirror is also Ankh so
an ak-shaped mirror is a visual Pun It's
a play on words
there's also a bit of magic involved in
mirrors
when you looked into one it captured
your image
look closely at the decoration in the
center
see the winged Scarab
it's holding a solar disk
now look very closely beneath the Scarab
it's a neb sign
and just above it are three plural
Strokes
this isn't just artistic decoration it's
spelling out one of the names of two
tank almond neb caporu Ray
we have two tank armors name in the
center
flanked by two cobras protecting the
king
they also hold Shen signs hieroglyphs
for eternity
so the center says neb caparu Ray
protected forever
this entire Tableau comes out of a Lotus
Flower a symbol of Resurrection
one of the treasures Carter found in the
Tomb is a wood head of Tutankhamun
coming out of a lotus flower
there were hieroglyphs running down the
left and right sides of the mirror case
let's translate the hieroglyphs on the
right side
there are a few words you won't know but
I'll help
with any text be it on the wall of a
temple an inscribed object or an
inscription on Papyrus you'll find words
you don't know
this is when you go to the big
dictionary like gardeners and try to
figure it out
but let's see what we do know
we'll go hieroglyph by hieroglyph
the first three are easy
the Anchor's life
the banner hieroglyph is God
and the nepher is good
the next hieroglyph is new
look at it carefully
it's part of a hieroglyph we're familiar
with
hint
think numbers
fractions
yes it's part of the eye of Horus
see it's the lower two pieces
this was pronounced tayat and it means
likeness
next we have the solar disk but no
stroke
so it's not day it's Rey the sun god
normally we might expect the god
determining of hieroglyph
but on something as small as the edge of
a mirror space is limited so
abbreviations are to be expected
next we have a word that looks familiar
but in a form slightly different from
what we used to
what word does it look like
yes per to go forth
remember the actual name of the Book of
the Dead is per M Haru the going forth
by day
this new word has the same root
but with some extra hieroglyphs
one is the little circle which usually
means something that comes in chunks
and there's some plural Strokes
we also have a loaf tea so it's feminine
the word means seed
and I think it does relate to the verb
to go forth after all seeds germinate
and bring forth life
it would have been pronounced something
like peret
this is followed by our God sign
and the hieroglyphs after that tell us
it's the adjectival form of God
naturally divine
so all together it's divine seed
next we have the water sign n and the
tethering ring Niche which means of
Divine seed of whom
well we have a God and it's our tomb
okay that makes sense
remember when we were talking about
myths and our tomb created the other
gods by himself well he did it by
masturbation which gives us the Divine
seed so two tank almond is being called
The Divine seed of atum
if we take this section from the top we
have the good God living likeness of Rey
Divine seed of atum
now let's continue with the inscription
we're familiar with all these
hieroglyphs
first is the sedge plant the symbol of
Upper Egypt
it's also the word for South and was
pronounced resi
this is followed by a b the symbol of
Lower Egypt
from our lecture on the names of the
Kings we remember that this is a
preamble to a king's name
then we have neb which means every all
and Lord
since we're dealing with the king's name
Lord's the best bet
Lord of what
the two lands those are two spits of
land
finally we come to the king's name neb
caparu Ray
which may mean something like the lordly
manifestation of Rey remember HEPA the
beetle means to exist
let's continue with the king's second
name
as we know the duck is pronounced saw
and means Sun
the solar disk doesn't have a stroke so
it doesn't mean sun or day again in this
case it means the sun god Ray even
though it doesn't have the god
determinative
as I said space is limited you expect
abbreviations
so two tank almond is the son of Rey
now the Cartouche
the Amun part comes first because of
honorific positioning the God's name is
always written first no matter how the
name was pronounced
then we have the tut part the loaf chick
loaf
and finally the ark so that's two tank
almond the living image of almond
but there is still some hieroglyphs in
the Cartouche to translate
we have the crook which was pronounced
heka and means ruler
remember how antutankhamun's coffins
he's shown holding the crook and flail
the symbols of kingship
I wouldn't be surprised if the Bishop's
Crook in Christianity didn't come from
Egypt
so two tank common is ruler of what
the next two hieroglyphs answer that the
first one a pillar was pronounced yunu
and it's the symbol of the city called
own in the Bible and heliopolis Sun City
by the Greeks we've seen that before
it's easy
so Tutankhamun is ruler of own
not the one in the North
the next hieroglyph our sedge plant is
the word for self
Tut is here called ruler of Southern own
which is Thebes or Luxor
the Cartouche is followed by two more
hieroglyphs we're familiar with
the first is D to give
and the last is ankh and we can read it
as given life
putting the whole thing together we get
the good God living likeness of Rey
Divine seed of atum king of Upper and
Lower Egypt lord of the two lands
nebcaparoo Ray son of Rey tutank almond
ruler of Thebes given life
that's the inscription on the right side
of the mirror
this mirror was used during two tank
almonds life there's nothing funerary
about the inscription
Tut isn't referred to as the Osiris or
anything like that
this was an inscription intended to be
seen by the living
but now let's look at something never
intended to be seen by the living
the lid of two tank almond sarcophagus
there's a mystery about the lid why is
it made of a different kind of stone
than the bottom part of the sarcophagus
the bottom what we call the sarcophagus
box is quartzite
while the lid is granite
one possibility is that the quartzite
bottom was already completed when two
tank almond died but the lid was not
because of tradition the body had to be
buried within 70 days
there may not have been enough time to
cut and transport a lid from the from
the quartzite Quarry so a slab of
granite available in Thebes was used
instead
the lid broke in half during ancient
times
perhaps when it was being lowered onto
the sarcophagus box
there was an attempt to repair it but in
the end the two halves were slid on top
of the box till they met and the crack
filled in with plaster and painted to
hide the brake
three elegant bands of hieroglyphs run
down the lid and I thought that for your
graduation exercise it would be
interesting to see how much you can
translate of the center band
the first three hieroglyphs are the
formula Jed medu words spoken
the serpent is shorthand for our verb to
speak tejed
the walking stick hieroglyph is medu and
means words
the Reed and the water sign is by so we
have words spoken by
okay by whom
yes enoop Anubis
and we have the Jackal determinative in
case you weren't sure
next comes the rabbit and water sign
women to exist
who shall exist
the Osiris
next word the king
next
so tutank almond because he's deceased
and in the realm of the Dead is called
the Osiris he is with the god of the
dead and like him he too will resurrect
next we have the statue base M which
just like the owl means in
then we have a very long word starting
with a goat skin that looks like a
headless animal
and ends with the house sign
the goat skin is the phonetic for canoe
and the word really means interior
which is why we have the house
determinative
however it later gained the meaning of
an Insider someone who is Among The In
Crowd
let's translate it simply as among
or with the m it could be in among and
in a second we'll see who the In Crowd
is
next word
yes we have three nature God banners
so two tank almond is in among the gods
naturu and the plural
but that's not all
next we have the plural of Lord
that's why the quail chick and the three
Strokes are there it would have been
pronounced nebu
but they aren't just any Lords
look at the next word
we have the star hieroglyph Dua and the
T and the house determinative it forms
the word duat the ancient Egyptian word
for the next world
so tutank almond will be hanging out
with the gods the Lords of the next
world
now the next word the face and stroke
I'm not sure about it
it could just mean with regard to or
concerning we can ignore it on our
translation it's not crucial
the following word is a new one
but from the feet determinative we know
it has something to do with walking
the bird is a Cormorant and it's an
accubird it's a bilateral the Q is the
phonetic complement
the word means to enter
so taught will enter
and what else what's our next word power
go forth
the word per doesn't have the usual feet
determinative because the word just
before it did and it can serve double
duty here and save the car for a
hieroglyph
so two tank almond will be in among the
gods the Lords of Eternity entering and
going forth
our next hieroglyph is a very important
one it's the ba not our Bob by literal
which is the bird with the leash
this bar has the head of a human
it also has a bowl of incense with smoke
rising from it the incense shows us it
has something to do with religion the
bow was crucial for immortality
you see the Egyptians believed that an
individual was made up of several parts
or aspects
we've already talked about some details
of the car
that was a kind of Astral double of the
deceased it needed sustenance offerings
had to be made for the car and that's
why we had the Cobb priest industry
the bar was more spiritual
need food but it had personality it was
what made you you that's why it's shown
with the head of a human
to a great extent these false doors that
we translated were created for the bar
to come and go it could fly in and out
perhaps in some way participating in
both worlds
there's a famous Egyptian Papyrus called
the report of a dispute between a man
and his bar that's as close to
philosophy as the ancient Egyptians ever
came
the dispute takes place during the first
intermediate period just after the Old
Kingdom era of pyramid building when the
government collapsed
the man is complaining that lawlessness
is everywhere robbers are on every road
there are no longer friends to turn to
he wants to kill himself
now comes the good part
his ba his alter ego tries to talk him
out of it
he tells the man that if he commits
suicide he the ba will desert him and he
won't be able to resurrect in the west
the idea is that you needed all aspects
of yourself to resurrect the body the
car and the bar without the bar there's
no immortality
the man tries to bribe his bar he tells
the bar that if he doesn't deserve him
the man will build such a wonderful tomb
for him that he will be the Envy of all
other bars
the bar will have no part of it and says
the man has to wait for a natural death
the point for us is that in the
inscription on the lid of Tutankhamun
sarcophagus we have Anubis guarantee
that two tank almond can come and go
like a bar
and look at the word that comes after
the word Ankh
two tank almond will be like a living
bar
the next hieroglyph the mouth r as you
know means two
but it can also have the sense of in
order to and that's what it means here
in order to do what
well the next two hieroglyphs are very
strange
they're two eyes of Horus I suspect they
mean to see
whom
Rey the Sun God but notice the arm is
backwards we have a left to right
reading text and the arm is carved as in
a right to left text scribal error
so Tut is going to come and go like a
living bar who will see Rey
what's the next word
yes it's weapon to shine or rise
this is the first hieroglyphic word you
learned at the very beginning of the
course when I asked you to guess the
meaning of web and Ray and pet
you've come a long way since then
notice how webinars failed on two tank
almonds lid
the sun hieroglyph doesn't come at the
end as a good determinative should it's
between the quail chick and the foot
I guess the Carver thought it would look
better that way remember all through the
course I've been saying you have to be
flexible with hieroglyphs there are very
few firm rules
after webbing we have what
yes a suffix pronoun Viper so Tut will
see Rey when he rises
look at the next word it's familiar to
us
it's hotep to be pleased but in this
context it means to set to rest to tank
almond will see Rey when he rises and
when he sets
and there's the Viper suffix for he sets
where will all this happen
our next hieroglyph is the statue base m
which just like the owl means in in
where the sky are familiar pet
what's the word that follows Sky yes
land and that makes sense the sun rises
in the sky and sets on land
the next three hieroglyphs form a
grouping we have seen before
when we were talking about the calendar
the sun with the stroke is the word for
day
and the neb sign is every
Tut will see the sun rise and set in the
sky and on Earth every day
now comes his name
first we have Saray son of Rey
then we can transliterate the name
easily to thank almond which is followed
by three hieroglyphs each with its own
meaning first the crook pronounced tekka
means ruler next again something we're
familiar with unu the city of heliopolis
but the next hieroglyph means Southern
and Southern yunu is Thebes ancient was
it isn't repetition great it's getting
easy
after the name is something we would
expect since this is in a sarcophagus
inscription
voice the euphemism for deceased
let me pause here for a moment to give
you a translation tip
when I'm in a tomb that's new to me and
I don't know whose tomb it is if I want
to find the name quickly I look for the
maharu hieroglyphs
and I know that the name of the deceased
will be right before it
so if you're in a museum looking at a
coffin with an inscription look for the
maharu and above it will be the name
then just sound it out phonetically
okay let's complete our translation
we're near the end
the next word is a preposition and it
means a million things near with in
front of loads of things like that so
let's see what comes next and then pick
the most appropriate meaning
well we know the next two hieroglyphs
nature ah the great God
so it's something like with the great
God next we have Lord
we should ask the usual question Lord of
what well we see the land hieroglyph so
it's a place
at the very end we have the foreign land
determinative so it's a far away place
we just have to figure out the
hieroglyph of the arm holding something
the arm is holding a ritual wand
the hieroglyph was pronounced jesser a
triliteral DJ s and r it means sacred or
holy so two tank almond will be with the
great God lord of the Sacred land
and that's the end of our inscription
let's read it from the top
words spoken by Anubis
there shall exist the Osiris the king
nebcaparoo Ray in among the gods the
Lords of the next world
who shall enter and go forth like a
living bar to see Rey when he rises and
he sets in the sky and land every day
son of Rey tutank almond true of voice
with the great God the lord of the
Sacred land
excellent you can really Translate
when I first began planning this course
I wasn't sure how much we could achieve
in 24 lectures
what we've done considerably more than I
anticipated
you can translate quite a bit
the hotep dinisu is now a familiar
friend and the basics of Egyptian
hieroglyphs are no longer a mystery
you can even translate the spectacular
jewelry of Middle Kingdom pharaohs
but understanding hieroglyphs is a skill
you shouldn't lose
so let me give you some suggestions for
how you can continue your study of
hieroglyphs
most important is to keep translating
this knowledge is indeed use it or lose
it
visit museums that have Egyptian
collections look for false doors
sarcophagi anything with inscriptions
and see what you can figure out
in America we have quite a few major
Egyptian collections New York has the
Metropolitan Museum of Art and the
Brooklyn Museum
although the Brooklyn Museum's Egyptian
collection is not generally well known
it's spectacular and it's never crowded
go there you'll love it
the Museum of Fine Arts in Boston has a
very large collection with many pieces
from the Old Kingdom that no other
museum has by all means visited it's
worth a trip
while we're on the East Coast I should
mention the University of Pennsylvania's
Museum
they too have a large and interesting
collection with lots of pieces to
translate
Chicago has two major collections one is
the University of Chicago's Oriental
Institute the Oriental Institute are
those guys doing the epigraphic surveys
copying all the inscriptions on almost
every Temple they can find
the other major Chicago collection is
the field museum another important
collection that is not well known
these are just the major collections in
the United States there are many smaller
collections all over the country that
you will enjoy visiting too
I think your visits to collections of
Egyptian objects have been forever
changed by this course
you know so much more now but still many
hieroglyphic inscriptions will stump you
this is where books come in
The crucial book will be sir Alan
Gardner's Egyptian grammar
it has almost everything you'll need to
continue your studies
there's a good dictionary in the back to
look up words you don't know and
there'll be plenty
there's also a sign list that includes
almost every hieroglyph you'll ever come
across
this list then leads you to an
explanation of the hieroglyph how it was
pronounced how it's used
looking up hieroglyphoids in Gardner's
book is like solving a mystery it's
great fun
the Gardner book also provides you with
a series of grammar lessons each with
exercises at the end so you can go
beyond what we've been able to achieve
here in 24 lectures
as wonderful as the book is
I do have two reservations about it
first it doesn't give the answers to the
exercises
second
it isn't an easy book to learn from on
your own but wait there's hope
there's a second book I want to
recommend
it was written by Dr Janice Cameron a
curator at the Metropolitan Museum of
Art
her book Egyptian hieroglyphs a
practical guide also has grammar lessons
with exercises to do but the answers are
in the back
it has objects to translate a dictionary
and it's user friendly
so this is the other book I recommend
to feed your general interest in ancient
Egypt I can suggest two organizations to
join first is the American Research
Center in Egypt called RC Arce
this is an organization of professional
and amateur egyptologists
if you join you'll get their journal and
newsletter
you can become a member of a local
chapter and you can attend lectures it's
really pretty good
it's a British counterpart the Egypt
exploration Society also has a journal
and newsletter that make Journey
worthwhile
they publish lots and lots of excavation
reports and other books on egyptology
and members get a significant discount
on any books they buy
they also have lots of back issues free
on the website
they too have lectures
one last suggestion is chemet magazine
named after the ancient Egyptian word
for Egypt
it's a popular magazine of egyptology
very slick beautiful color with articles
written by Leading egyptologists for a
popular audience I'm sure you'll enjoy
it
now
before I lose you
let me show you my secret hieroglyphs
in the background set for our entire
course have been these familiar panels
of hieroglyphs
they are the credits for the course
there have been many people who helped
make this course possible and the
hieroglyphs tell us just a few of who
they are
this is one that might have been the
title for our course
I bet you can translate it
yes writing in ancient Egypt
for some of the titles of people
involved in our course I had to fudge it
a bit since there was no comparable
titles in ancient Egypt for example what
do you do for academic content
supervisor
can you see what I did
yes the first word is overseer
of what
knowledge it's pretty close
Now What's his name first name
sound it out
Brandon good
second
Hopkins yes Hopkins thank you Brandon
we had a producer
here's what I did for that
first word
mistress
the next word
the I and the t is doing or getting done
next word yes things
she was Mistress of getting things done
I abbreviated her first name to just two
hieroglyphs what is it
yes Jen
second name is easy yep great thanks Jen
Gray
we also had someone who did all the
picture research and found wonderful
images for us
her title is
yes overseer feminine of course of what
toot yes images she's the overseer of
the images
what's her first name
yes Abby
for her last name I had to use the
ptolemaic lion for the L or she wouldn't
have had any name thank you Abby LOL
we had an art director but as you know
there was no word for art in ancient
Egypt so the best I could do
was overseer of the sculptors her name
sounded out
first name
Marcy good second it's Irish
Cochran thanks Marcy
one last group of guys who are
absolutely essential are cameramen
well our three men hieroglyphs means men
that's easy
next word
yes to go forth
and there's toot Yes Men of the moving
image thank you all
there's just one last panel and it's my
wish for all of you
I know you can translate it
may you be given life stability
Prosperity like Rey forever
so now it's graduation time
to throw your cap in the air and feel
good about what you've accomplished and
remember this course is kind of like the
movie Groundhog Day
you can play it again and again and if
you do I'll see you then